you can either live your dreams or live
your fears I think the majority of
people actually not living your dreams
but a living their fears
there's absolutely no reason in the face
of the earth that you should not reach
for every single bright star
I give everything that you got be that
last August I was told that in all
likelihood I had three to six months
left to live somebody said to me in
light of those numbers wow so you're
really beating the Grim Reaper and what
I said without even thinking about is we
don't beat the reaper but by living
longer we beat the reaper by living well
and living fully for the reaper will
come for all of us the question is what
do we do between the time we were born
and the time he shows up imagine if you
will being on your deathbed and standing
around your bed the ghosts of the dreams
the ideas the abilities the talents
given to you by life with you for
whatever reason you never pursued those
dreams you never acted on those ideas
you never use those gifts you never use
those talents and then they are staring
at you as you're lying on your bed with
large angry eyes saying we came to you
only you could have given us life and
now we must die with you forever
greatness is not some esoteric quality
that only a few of us have it's not this
god-given gift that is predetermined
among us and only a few people have this
unique quality to ever achieve great no
greatness lies every single one we all
have the ability to become free but the
difference lies in what we're willing to
do to get there and how we're going to
do it you know there's a certain
redemptive power that making a choice
don't be afraid to fail go and
experience life instead of reading about
it don't experience life instead of
asking someone else tell
go out there mail love and scrape your
knees go out there and do the wrong
thing that way you now have and
experience an accident tool to support
you in the building of your life
once you make a decision and you go
all-in and you say I quit and I get
there I'm giving up I'm giving it I will
do whatever it takes you whatever it
takes I'll do whatever it takes to be
successful and when you make that
decision you when you look you in the
mirror and you tell yourself that look
I'm true I'm I'll do whatever it takes I
get that's the day you'll see Hill
begins to happen you the people have the
power the power to create machines the
power to create evidence
you the people have the power to make
this life free and beautiful to make
this life a wonderful adventure
all to reach their dreams now
are you thirsty
it's a recent dream
we should go
be a wok moving this
is not too
and it's going to be great
joy is one day
we feel great
oh isn't it dream
a rich that moment it's your mindset
change you know what I believe I believe
your greatness is already your greatness
is already in you you just gotta get it
out what you need to do is look at that
person in the mirror look at their
reflection and tell that person you will
do you can do the cemetery there you see
potential never realize there you find
books never written there you find ideas
never acted on maybe that's why Henry
David Thoreau said Oh God to reach the
point of death all that you realize that
you've never lived only to realize that
you've never scraped the surface of your
potential when I look up at the night
sky and I know that yes we are part of
this universe we are in this universe
but perhaps more important than both of
those facts is that the universe is in
us
I want to do good I want the world to be
better because I was here I want my life
I want my my work of my family I wanted
to mean something and it's like it has
if if you are not making someone else's
life better then you're wasting your
time
whatever the mind can conceive and
believe the mind can achieve regardless
of amun at times you may have failed in
the bed or how long they or aims and
hopes may be but all there will ever be
is what's happening and the decisions we
make in business which are based in
either love or theater choose love and
don't ever let fear turn you against
your playful heart